thanks guys um usually you know up my
talks are usually on tutorials on that
kind of stuff deep into technology it
and so this is a change in my this thing
talking about things which are slightly
at a higher level on the other hand of
the we do you know there are things that
we need to understand I that the what we
do and why we do what we do right we
need to have the meta view and
interestingly it is good that PI data
has a few of these talks I see that the
looking forward to the keynote today
afternoon talking about system view of
machine learning as well as things like
data informed versus data-driven so
there are a lot of interesting topics I
talk about these things hmm like the you
know once you look at or once one looks
at the higher level of what are we doing
and the system's view it is like the
blue pill and the red pill right once
you take the take the red pill then you
go in a direction and there are a lot of
things that you realize happen anyway
without much further ado let me and go
to the next slide I thing already
introductions are done so I'm going to
leave it alone the only thing is you
know I'm doing my masters in computer in
a computational finance he also have a
connection to the you over Seattle area
um let us first quickly look at the
background right what are the what does
it mean in a in an analytics big data
world like the proverbial blind people
looking at an elephant right everybody
has multiple views to the same domain so
the first one first of all big data of
course he's about analytics like most of
the time what we are looking at is we
are taking a big data and analytics is
the first one second we are building
model
we are building models one way or the
other about the nodes right and then the
models go and work on things on the
unknown unknowns right so so there is I
got to understand that what we we have a
tiny view into a domain and based on
that view we develop an understanding of
the domain and then be projected in that
sense I think the on-ramps well did a
good job explaining the domain they the
known unknowns and unknown unknowns and
all those things another interesting
point right the ESD known unknown point
right the things are known but it is
none it is unknown to our model and this
is where evolving models commended you
put the model in and then at the models
evolve as they you know as they start
getting more and more information as
they work on the project so that is an
important work and that is where the
data scientist has a devil right as a
devout person it is very important that
you think of it that way not as a model
that we develop and throw it over the
wall and simply implemented it's more
like that right you you realize that yup
I have a model I developed with
incomplete information now I need to
look at and say how can I evolve this
one and that is part of the data science
work second one it is a pipeline it is a
pipeline you have the the very clear-cut
data management and data science domains
write the data management is the collect
store and transform right those are the
prettiest things then you have the the
reason and model and then you deploy
those things then the whole visualize
rectum and predict explore domains the
reason to understand is that when we
develop or for things like transactional
systems and order entry it's a lot
easier right you know where things are
it's very you know it's very clear-cut
he can look at it and say okay what does
it mean this is where it comes in i put
this one in any other but here it is not
right you have a lot more interactivity
lot more systems view
a lot of things but as we will see more
we will see that it's a lot more systems
view and we need to think about the
whole pipeline not just a tiny piece of
it three of the the I'm sure you have
heard of the volume velocity variety
these are the three big data stuff but
there is more to it there is a conduct
and connectedness right like we talked
about the the social network the even
graphs are you know important in many
other places then there is also the
inference intelligence and the interface
right the three eyes it's important to
think in this area and look at it and
say okay this is intelligence is all my
algorithms now I have an inference that
I make on that one and then I'm able to
bring the interface to a to the
appropriate project maybe it is a
dashboard maybe things unless they have
a couple of slides we talks about them
the the various designs and the
architectures this we talked about
earlier the data scientist ever write
the data scientist has to think that
person has to think as a dev up person
and think of it as a right you have the
lab analytics in the lab we go in you
develop the models you based on things
you know and then you also have
analytics in the factory where you need
to you are you go in a world of
automated systemic were right and the
couple of interesting things am sure you
all agree you all have come across at
this one the even if you put a satiric
models you got to explain it the model
should be explainable they should be
transparent otherwise it will it's not
going to work it so those are some of
the things that you have to think
through and say I know these things now
when I go in I also have to think of
when when it is in production what are
the things i need to do what are the
implications of that one and finally i
think no sofa now here will agree on
that one data is your product it doesn't
regardless of what yourself right data
is the view to a business and the pulse
a couple of interesting this things like
collect the right data through
thoughtful design it it's not get
all if you type in a gut to have the
right data that means you gotta think
through and say what kind of things do I
want to collect what kind of things do I
want to store how do I want to store it
what kind of relationships do you want
to catch her and it doesn't end there
right give the data back in a powerful
way like the users how to you know I am
sure we all have seen huge dashboards
right that that have all kind of things
in there right and then don't overwhelm
the user right use the users how to feel
safe they have to feel in control that
is where you look at it and say maybe
things like the drill down right so you
see a view they can they can say no no I
want this one I want this one they pull
it in they drill down now users are in
control they are able to interact with
the data there is another interesting
aspect to it is the is is actually not
about the technology but the way you
develop a product right the complicated
product never launched a complicated
data product especially on a data
product because what happens is it
becomes 20 lemming for the users it
becomes too difficult to manage you you
need the feedback you slowly I try to
you Lee you know develop the product you
slowly add the features and now the
users are able to adopt your product URL
so you will turn up the product because
now you realize what things are
happening where things are happening
that kind of stuff anyway these are
about three or four points just to keep
in mind and let us go into the theater I
like this picture this this is
interesting I haven't gone there yet I
think one of this is a lot of oil and
see how it is this is the the History
Museum in London let us walk I we have
all seen this one people talk about data
lakes and data hubs and that kind of
stuff in the end they end up in a debt a
swamp right the company comes in it says
we need Hadoop we need spark we need
sure ml etc suddenly all these things
come in be people by machines or they go
into the cloud they get all these things
in you have data coming in they dead
occurring all over the place after three
months what happens everything is you
know it is a mishmash
are all kind of things going in suddenly
people they say I can't take the data
out right I can't use it because this
has different semantics to it the attack
Eurasian is an important one when you
put the data in when you think when you
build a system don't start creating
parka files or you know CSV files
without thinking through and say okay
how does it fit in the bigger system if
a dieta a curation it need not be you
know very esoteric as you don't need
huge systems but at least make sure that
you publish a schema make sure the data
is there the files are there they are
organized well and the end they can work
together I have a few other things that
it occurred yesterday there was an
interesting talk right the van was
talking about the data gravity and the
data marts right you need the right
gravity and the right mass you don't
want a molasses there right you want the
right level of data gravity and that
aids your systems video this was an
interesting looking at LinkedIn and I
thought this was an interesting as I was
preparing this one I saw this blog do
you have a layer right in it may not be
exactly like this but at least it gives
you the feel of you have a governance of
some sort we have the cleansing it can
be all of these pieces but you realize
that yeah this looks like an interesting
way of organizing data so that is fine
you have the data lay all these things
are working we you know a big data to
know where this is an a this this
actually happens a lot more probably
than we think in many ways right people
go in people start putting data in there
is this huge you know Hadoop
infrastructure whatever it is you have
all the big data sitting in there so the
business comes in and says hey what's
going on I want to see something they
say yeah I have the big data I have the
Hadoop everything is there so and yes
you can see you know you can actually
see the HDFS you can see the spark GUI
and the business roxy senses huh right
because they what they are looking at
his capabilities right so what you got
to look at and say I need to
will the full stack I don't want to go
and build one I have a couple of slides
we talked about it they MEP they let me
for example instead of that one if you
know if you start with the logs for a
right you put the logs in you are able
to make some inference business comes in
and says so yeah what is going on you
can say hey looking at the loss it looks
like you know people are buying our
product one o'clock between 1 and 2 a.m.
right because I can see that that is
where the maximum transactions are and
looking at something it looks like i
don't know male 30 to 40 or whatever I
tell you now the business is interested
they look at and say oh yeah that that
looks interesting so tell me how much
how much of our revenue is coming from
that particular segment then you can go
back and say oh no no we haven't yet put
the order in order data isn't but we can
so now you have an interactive in a now
there is a way of so this is how you
interactively will do that one don't go
in and put all the things in one place
and say hey I have the data that doesn't
solve the problem that you have to have
the inferences going back I can the one
of the a quick canonical architecture
right um you have the the data hub
rightly we have some level of landing
zone and then you have a data hub that
is where like we talked about earlier
you have a curated data that goes in the
data hi and there is also a in memory
alright if we do have the real time so
keep in mind that there could be things
that you need to do real time so you
also have a real time hub of subside and
then the other side is the analytics up
that is fair all the analytics live and
we have the reporting hub right there
will be so now what happens you have the
data comes in it goes in it is sitting
there in a curated area you have a place
for analytics of course I have put the
you know the all the Python Python
libraries of course you're all familiar
with the various libraries and the
frameworks that you can use and so the
first thing that happens is you have a
you know people will look at it and say
hey I need a dashboard and I need
reports right reports reports need not
be just reports they could be like we
were saying earlier right
the users control to pivot the data view
the users control to look at the data in
different ways give the users to select
data subsets right so all those things
happen at the reporting but then the
that is where you know a talk about the
faster response with aggregated data
subsidy for example somebody will come
up and say hey I want to compare the
uniques between you know this year and
last year a computing the uniques over
multiple dimensions is a big task right
and if you want exact uniques that's a
lot more you know you not more
computational etc right so now you can
see where they are now I can run the
analytics and I can give you the results
say for example in a couple of hours all
right so now you have bifurcated the
things you have put the things in place
and you also have a dashboard now you
develop this stack right so that you
have these things in place for a slit
data set and then as you add more data
into your data hub you can do more
analytics you can do more in memory this
thing and in the ecosystem growth
instead of just developing the data the
next slide like this this this I like
this picture right the the MVP stack
right you don't go in and say okay let
me start building the wheels but right
bill building a instead of that one you
give them the the simple write a simple
way of moving around and then you add
more things to it right then you add
perp you know it's you know you make it
a bike you make it a car etc etc of
course you can look at it and see if I
want a car as no gore is not going to
help ride the skateboard is not going to
wait which is true but the but the this
thing is at least you can move right you
don't know that you need a car maybe you
need something else right so this I
thought captures the essence of how the
MVP of an analytic stack and the at
least of pieces right you have to look
at it and say what are the pieces I need
how do i combine these things too
so anyway that is the web the arm if you
take one lesson out of this stuff I
think this should be saying that I want
to build a hole bigger picture rather I
want to build the stack and how data
slices rather than just build a data hub
which is fine but then if it takes a lot
more time to develop it then and also
you don't know what all things that
people need so which is fine now let us
look at the next one a data too far this
is interesting right because this we all
have come across ID how CSV file see how
the GZ files all these things are
running around because what happens is
this is big data right you you might
have things you might have captured some
features in some place and then suddenly
what happens again the same story write
the data grows it's very difficult for
somebody to combine things together in
fact one of the things that got to look
at is the putting the data together from
different areas right that itself is a
big task it is not the computation it is
a ability to get these things together
semantically coherent and that itself is
an important that is where things like
data pipelines that come in ensure the
correctness the temporal congruence is
important because he how data which says
okay this is a transactional data it is
you know per hour per minute whatever it
is and then you have something else
which says okay this is aggregated at up
a week or per month they have to come
together right if this is 1 through 15
and this is you know 10 to 20 then there
is no way you can compare compare 120
once you aggregate it there is no way
you can take it apart the next one is
more interesting like this this is the
very sad toefl right this is all fine so
we have the right data we have it this
thing now we start putting interesting
algorithms on the top of the lid what
happens for example i'm sure you all
heard of the netflix price right
who who who has in head of the netflix
place nobody hey good yet my patient
does it that way anyway so the netflix
price right it was to find they they had
a million-dollar bounty on it people
they'd all kind of stuff there are huge
and samples i think 50 in samples or
something like that coming together 50
algorithms coming together you got the
lift up what was a ten percent that
point one point they got the lift
everything is fine so now you look back
and say oh yeah so did they implement it
no they did right they did not implement
they may have put part of it they didn't
implement the whole thing the reason was
that even though you got a lid it was a
lot more difficult to implement that is
one second they mowed off so one of the
interesting things about netflix right
arm you know that now they are producing
shows you know why they are producing
shows it's because a very simple reason
right in they have gone past to the
rating of one to five they actually know
the semantics of movies if you looked at
the semantics you can see that they have
movies which say movies which show
whatever you know rain in in Prague with
the you know with the hero and the hero
in walking away whatever it is it's not
working i were to the sm romantic this
thing for example or they can look at it
and say car chase in the middle of a
highway with a lot of fire right so they
actually know the semantics of what
people watch so once you know the
semantics of what people watch they can
easily go back to the you know writers
and say i don't know what you write but
i need these six things right it's very
easy to say that right it's very though
you have you can look at it and say that
is where they are not having the show's
right if you look at the develop the
shows you can see that there are things
that they develop the it's not fine you
know you're not going to go and say ho i
need a show that gets by rating and say
I need a show they look at it and say
yeah I need a show where there is this
politician person they would look at and
say yeah Kevin Spacey i think is a
person to do it suddenly you've got a
thing coming up and that is sucky and
that is the inside the ability to take
ability to take that thing
but already a feather it is a TV show or
rather it is you know I should be
careful talking about Amazon because I'm
sure there's a lot of certain folks here
so you know whether it is about things
in Amazon and satire you look at it you
are able to take it apart and you can
say why are these people bought this one
day they will also buy this one because
of various reasons it is not because
just a sure you know the shopping cart
affinity small like that yeah and then
you can look at it and say people who
like this maybe they like this
particular thing as well which is no
more they are not the same but they
shall and the ability to understand
these things that's important on the
other hand you also have to look at it
and say just because there is a
statistical significance that does not
mean it's a business significant you
know that there is a huge there is a a
lot of discussions about the p-values
right people are looking at I'm saying p
values you don't use P values use the
statistical significance the reason is
this right you look at and say oh yeah I
have worked up you know the pp value is
less than point or five which is fine it
is it is it is not bad because it is an
indicator but just looking at and that
one saying it by heart a p-value this
one we should do it immediately it's not
the solution right you have to look at
it and say yes I got this one but what
is it oh yeah I got a lift of point or
two or window so you look at it and say
he said significant is it significant
for me to say okay change my you know I
don't know ABT testing change my view of
the navigation or things like that right
and so those things have to consider
before we go in and put a model in
practice the this the the what Martin
was talking about right knowledge is a
process of piling of facts and wisdom
lies in their simplification and that's
important you simplify it to a point and
look at it and say yes this makes sense
this makes sense from a statistical
significance point of view this also
makes sense from a business on the other
hand you also have to have the other
side yes because you know for example
were things that we've been i'm working
on forecasting right you do you do the
forecasting but you also have to have
statistical significance in your
forecasting so that when people look at
it and say how did you forecast what
kind of things have when you look at and
say yep there is enough statistical
for me to say that yep this this deal
with the reasonable listening this makes
so let us go to the this is an
interesting one right I'm sure you all
have followed the the UK general
election as well as the grease this
thing right in both cases these are
interesting times for analytics right in
both cases the polls were totally Paul's
got it really late way around right the
polls guarded mirror the reason they got
it this the i will have been i saw this
in twitter i thought that this is the
right one right the the most the biggest
danger of analytics is this getting
reasonable looking answers from a
reasonable looking data set that is flat
all right you look at the dancer here
this makes sense it doesn't make sense
of that the reason is this right there
are there are things like publication
bias right you only public open up you
the publication comes out of only the
things it's a filter this thing right it
is not everything doesn't get you know
you don't get it published whatever it
is there is this this concept of a now
homogeneous and sample right homogeneous
and sample is an oxymoron right if you
had an example and if they all think do
the same thing it doesn't make any sense
where you need an advance I'm we just
need one of them right uniden samples
that then don't agree they disagree they
look at it and say no no I am looking at
this part of this thing and I don't
think this is right right and then the
the same as a file dollar effect right
the things that have lot of things that
go under the files are they get filed
and they never see this thing you don't
see that one so these things are
important and I see the you know yogi
where I said a you can see a lot just by
looking it's true it's a and you know
the the the UK elections and Greece ones
right they were an eye opener in that
sense you should have seen the right I'm
sure he has seen the before the purple
so close they'll say oh I desire that
this is huge this thing right but in the
end it cut totally you know it was
better way wrong and this was on a span
of a few days I'd it is not like a span
of months or something like that it's
not like seasonality
some unforeseen things happened no none
of these so the key is this right don't
torture the data right if you torture
the data it will tell you what you want
to hear but that's not what you wanted
so the the whole I'm not going to go
into details but this hole in our area
of like you know that the overfitting
the bias with you know variance trade
also all kinds of things come in the
picture as well as looking at the right
data looking at multiple algorithms all
of this and then this will become more
important this will become a lot more
important as we get into more and more
interesting analytics late and and as we
start it's not as we start probably even
now as we start depending on machine
learning and analytic systems and big
data right the all these things come
together and we start depending on them
then we have to have developed the
systems in such a way that we are able
to at least differentiate between them
there is this whole there is this whole
line of thought which talks about
outliers like they really have not
outlier side you got to look at the man
said we need to look at and say they are
not out layers it so you have to look at
the message they are saying something
that we don't understand out we don't
see or that something that we need to
look at this is an interesting US
government sorry UK government of you
get the same principle excellent are
nice this thing right so you look at the
first one right it says start with needs
could you tell me whose needs they are
talking about there is a nice tricks in
there right any thoughts customer not
the governments needs that's why they
put an asterisk in it and if they say
look at the need of the customer don't
look at the needs for the government
right so excellent thank you design with
data understand the concept right build
digital services be consistent not
uniform very interesting excellent
insights when we start building data
RX I just wanted to you know put it in
such that I thought this is a very in a
way so taking that team to the next
level right data Ilan is not enough this
is another I don't know how much this
thing right you can look at it and say
give me some data I'll be able to make
sense of it maybe maybe that because it
is also in it is it is induction it's
not deduction right you cream so
mathematical you can you can detect but
this is not this is a lot more than Matt
right this is the data you do need to
understand some parts of the domain for
example the ROC curve right if you look
at the ROC curve maybe you look at it
and say where should I you know the
should I go you know less of this one or
you know for for example if you are
looking at say e the legal this thing
right what do they call it exploration
or right in that point where you want is
you want to capture all the things that
you want to you want to capture
everything that you can even if there
are another false positive versus false
negatives all those things that you want
to capture you want to make sure that
you capture everything so the question
is this right how much of that you
capture are right and on the other side
how much of right did you capture right
how much of right did you capture is
what is important in some other places
on the other hand for example insert the
question is how much of that you capture
are right right if you have first to
five elements that are wrong even if the
rest of them are right if the search is
done right anyway there's an interesting
i serve on where were set there was i
don't know where it is they said that
you can actually hide a dead body in the
page 2 of a certain thing right hello so
it's invested it nobody looks at page 2
this episode so the theme so those
things are important to say the so and
that depends on the domain beam and the
other thing of course is this is more
for the managers right machine
is not magic right you cannot you cannot
expect gold from a pack of data led some
saliva it might be exaggerating but
still you that the data has to have
enough knobs and dials you should have
enough things to move all right it
should be able to tell if the data is
not expressive enough you will not be
able to get things or you can peep then
a lot of this thing going on which is ok
I hope we have the data so let us make
some inferences I gotta look at this and
say guys he can't you got to have you
know things in there to make inferences
the taking that one to the next one
right this is this of course is you know
Google saw this thing right moreleta
beats clever algorithm that also is
interesting right spend time on
algorithms that grow with the data many
models of course you know the like we
talked about earlier in samples learn
from multiple models do the in samples
make sure that you have enough you have
enough breath in your algorithms breath
in your data so that you are able to
manage the club of course the last one I
think this is my last slide correlation
does not imply causation like that we
know we all know that one but still it
needs to be set you know every German we
talk about these things so in short
build a full stack I trade you I don't
go in until the whole site build it I
creatively learn from the domain
identify the right business problems
create valuable data perspectives that's
like that i think is an SN site you
create interesting and valuable data
perspectives frame the problems and
finally embed inference and intelligence
into products like 2pm but this is the
the i think i had written a blog earlier
in LinkedIn one of it The this is like
the electronics right earlier people had
electronics and there were engineers who
would go out and say I want to amber you
know I'm helping my customers to em but
electronics in their product
right now Electronics is there
everywhere is the V so similarly
intelligence and inference I am burning
them in various pub in the products and
that's what in anything that you do from
any area that you work on and that is
where the keys that's where the machine
learning data science all these things
will become interesting thank you very
much and I left it you have how much
time yeah good good excellent I don't
want to I was taking a chance but I said
I'm going to leave 10 minutes out for
folks to talk about you know suggestions
any things that you have seen in your
this thing right rather than me talking
the whole time I'm living up to up to
the folks to say okay folks what what do
you think did it make sense is it the
right there the good the bad and the
ugly any brave souls too yes sir each
way ah thank you what about your
experience in every NEX you know people
who are seen that if they might I'm sure
you how see there are experience where
you look at it and say hey this has
happened to me we have built in right we
have built the things you thought and
the business is in the coming asking
questions that kind of stuff it is fine
yeah
need to sort of decentralized data oh
yeah absolutely absolutely absolutely
thank you thank you that is that was my
point about embedding diligence in the
products the time has come right that
keynote was excellent time has come
right but what are you talking about
well thank you thank you for it was
beautiful right usually we look at it
and say we collect all the daytime and
then we put it in this big place right
and then we have this park or whatever a
thermal or whatever it is he starts
running on these things right in
Sherrill that one we have to look at it
and say I want to em but this
intelligence in the in the wherever the
data is right and and the he was talking
about the g you know the aircraft right
i think in a five terabytes of data per
flight from boston to san francisco or
whatever at a site or sometimes it's
called abortion which already said so
i'm taking that data and putting it in
using it immediately right it is and
that is going to happen what will happen
is all these tiny things it's not
they're not tiny anymore right they will
have intelligence built in they will be
able to take the data in they will be
able to make things that we need to make
but there is one point in there the one
of the things that happens is you have
to look at it there is a systems
principle which says put the feature at
the lowest layer possible in the sense
that if you put it any layer lower you
lose the context right for example if
you want to look at and say if just for
like if all the cows are there and they
want to go into one direction that
cannot be made by one cup right you got
to look at it and say we're all all
others going and then you have to go it
just product I know it says so on the
other hand if you put the intelligence
at a higher level what happens is you
lose the the control right because now
you have to look at it yet wait for the
data you have to do this one then send
back it says oh do this one so that
balance has to be there between the
control and the context of course Rober
the whole this parameter servers for
the be planning what it does is because
deep learning is it has to be
distributed right the capability has to
be distributed you have we have multiple
clusters are multiple the boxes running
all these things and there is a
parameter server and they update the
parameters are so they get best of the
both worlds they can look at their part
of the this thing and do their this
thing as well as they can exchange the
context rate they can put the elevate
the context to it to a next level thank
you excellent good question thank you
and there are two more talks coming up I
am looking forward to that one like I
was saying earlier the today afternoon
right systems view of machine learning
that should be beautiful and the second
is data in form versus data-driven those
are a couple of interesting talks that
that looks at it from this going
yep yep yeah probably thank you thank
you thank you yeah excellent yeah
together with qualitative yeah yeah I
should have put non-quantitative
information thank you thank you thanks
guys appreciate it